okay let me tell you my experience Dan I
have seen that many times I've seen men
laugh at each other for like oh my
girlfriend hit me you should have been a
man you should have like thug it out but
do you understand that maybe the guys
you hang out with are the guys that you
they're so-called toxic because the
masculine men that I'm talking about
would never do
that my name's John it's been 5 years
since I directed an episode on this
exact same topic and it has only grown
more relevant so let's jump into our
discussion between feminist and men's
rights activists men already have all
their rights if you agree step
forward let's start
with I hate the name men's rights
activists because it does imply that as
if our rights are being taken away the
problem that men face is more
existential the patriarchy conditions
men or assigned male at Birth people to
pretty much just keep your feelings shut
down by age 10 your feelings don't
matter and then 12 through 13 and
onwards you're just don't really feel
like you matter much as a person and I
don't think anybody's disagreeing with
that our rights aren't really under
attacked meanwhile half of Congress
hasn't codified roie way they're trying
to control women's bodies and it's just
ridiculous like our rights aren't under
attack but a lot of women's rights are
and I think it's important that we fight
for that right I also think that there's
a difference between like rights and
inequality yeah of so I don't think that
my right's being taken away I think
that's just an effect of patriarchy I
agree um we're not like losing our
bodily autonomy uh we're not you know
fearing for our lives walking down a
dark hallway you know so I don't think
they're comparable I agree
yeah yeah I think when um you look at
most of the world's leaders are men most
judges are men look at even our Supreme
Court there's nine judges and how many
are women you know it's the fact that
women had to fight and ask to in 1974
get access to have their own bank
account like that's absurd that's absurd
that you know just because there's a
little a little um clause in the
Constitution it says all men men being
equal they're going to be play dumb and
act like that that means just men it
doesn't mean human and for women to have
to fight for anything to be equal to a
man is just it's ridiculous it proves
that men have their right they they're
the ones that set the rights they're the
ones that if that's most of our Senate
our house our Congress everybody they're
the ones that vote over the laws and
things that get passed they have the
rights and they're the ones that dish
them to everybody else and you're lucky
if you can get them and we also need to
remember men's right activism while they
do have some genuine plights it started
out as a combatant to feminism so I feel
like they laid the groundwork off a very
um bad Foundation no I honestly I 100%
agree I think the I think it's been
hijacked by a lot of bad faith actors
who blame women for problems that you
should blame the patriar exactly exactly
and it's very frustrating because
I'm on this side because I think that
there is genuine problems that I think
need to be addressed I'm sure we can all
agree on that what are some of those
problems High suicide rates men are four
times as likely to um I don't know what
the Tik Tok version of the phrase is but
you know four times more likely I think
that's something that should be talked
about more I think that there's also a
lot of men are very hesitant to get rid
of the Notions of patriarchy whereas
I've noticed a lot of women or assigned
female birth people are very willing to
just throw away any Notions of
femininity I think a lot of men have a
lot of emotional baggage from the
patriarchy that they redirect at women
and it's not fair to them and it's also
hurting us right and the problem is is
for some men all they have is their
notion of masculinity to the point that
they cannot let it go and they can't see
anything else other than that when the
actuality is again gender isn't real
we're just plants with complicated
emotions when I look at people I just
see human shaped flowers yeah I would
agree with you I would say that a lot of
these men's rights activists they're
struggling like you said they have high
suicide or high self deltion whatever
we're supposed to say don't know what
the word and the way they're coping
withs yeah and the way that they're
coping with it is by saying okay we're
having this issue so we need to put
women back exactly and be this yeah we
need to take away their rights we need
this Society to be the way it was where
like all the rights that were afforded
to people it was men men were the first
people to get rights and then other
people have to especially White
and then everyone else has to catch up
to them and because they're struggling
they go oh let's turn the clock back
number one that's impossible you're not
going to turn the clock back and number
two I don't think that's actually going
to help the issue it's not going to help
the issue he'll hindle it on the suicide
thing I do think it's important to have
a little bit of nuance that women
actually attempt suicide far more often
the reason why men are more successful
as it is because they're more likely to
own a firearm and use it um but in terms
of uh like men fighting for rights I
think that like um movements that
attempt to fight for rights uh for
particular groups that that sort of
description should be um exclusive to
genuine social justice movements you
know there may there may be disparities
and ways in which the the patriarchy
does uh disadvantage men but I think
that um you can't co-opt the language of
it being a social justice a rights based
movement no that's the problem is that
like I have this thing I say I feel like
saying that like men have feelings it's
kind of like saying all lives matter
because men only ever bring up their
problems directly after women up theirs
so it just sounds dismissive and that's
the problem is that for a lot of men I
think we feel so uncared for by Society
we feel so like just like we don't
really matter unless we prove our worth
that anytime any social movement gets
any sort of traction we just immediately
just bum rush that and it really makes
me wonder that there are rational men's
right activists seeing as yourself but
are these people advocating Bad actors
for women's rights to be peeled back for
for them to to feel comfortable I think
I think the I think so cuz I think the
problem is that a lot of men again
people who are so rooted in their gender
bother me because it only hurts you it
only hurts other people around you it's
kind of like the idea of like cuz the
problem is that men are allowed to
express anger but they're not allowed to
express sadness women are allowed to
express sadness but you cannot express
anger or else they get called like a
yeah exactly I've never heard one
men's rights activists talk about like
men the loneliness epidemic of men not
having friends it's always like women's
problem AG they don't want to date you
they don't want to they never offer any
solutions no Solutions so this is this
is a great opportunity to bring in our
disagre but I please I ask that we
listen to what they have to say before
we disagree with
them so the perspective that I come from
was about three years ago I wanted to
know why men didn't want to get married
anymore I kept hearing men say I don't
want to get
married and it kind of took me down the
rabbit hole of family court I started
interviewing men that had been what's
called divorce
graped and I kept finding guy after guy
after guy that lived a couple miles from
his kids and could not see them it goes
back to men should have access to their
children it's 50% their DNA they should
get 50% custody off the bat and right
now 90% of the time women get custody
the question was do men have all of
their rights how can I say that they
have all of their rights when I'm
finding guy after guy after guy that is
devastated he can't talk to his children
I had one guy who the woman got
custody and she ended up taking the kid
to a different country and now his kid
doesn't speak his same language he spent
$300,000 trying to get that kid back I
want to look at Women's stories as to
why they don't want to get married and I
could go interview a thousand women
you're looking for these kinds of men
what she's discussing are individual and
yes tragic cases and we can acknowledge
that but we're what we are discussing is
a systemic issue on aggregate men and
women after divorce women see a 27%
decline in the reduction of their income
they are more likely to be in poverty
and they are less likely to get
remarried if you go around the world
there are countries that have male only
conscription countries that have higher
pension ages for men uh countries like
the US and Canada have certain welfare
programs that men are excluded from
domestic violence laws homeless laws
there are many cases where men do not
have access to the same uh Public
Welfare programs tax paid programs and
if you look at something like the draft
in the US people say well that's um
outdated doesn't happen anymore but many
countries in the world included some
that are considered like very first
world Progressive feminist countries
Austria Finland Switzerland they have
male only conscription and many
countries have higher pension ages for
men so there is there are many examples
of countries that have laws that
directly discriminate against men so do
we have all the rights I mean no we
don't in the US I had to volunteer well
not really volunteer I wasn't given a
choice but I had to register for the
draft so that's a small example but it's
you know one that still goes on today
going back to the family court thing
because we want to talk about
traditional relationships and that's how
it should be the mom should stay home
with the kids and the dad is the
provider and all that but then when it
comes to the family court we want to be
like oh dads need 50% custody but you
don't even know you're kid you've been
off providing all this time and the only
reason now you want 50% custody is
because that's the only that still
connects you to the woman or whatever up
reason you have but it has nothing to do
with the children at heart it has to do
with I'm their father I deserve 50%
custody but where were you the first 10
15 years that we were raising the kids
I'm not denying that they need their
mothers or their fathers more men and
women compliment each other that is what
I'm saying some men are more masculine
some women are more feminine my
girlfriend's more feminine I'm more
masculine we go very well together
because our values align what
no but hold on what is feminine to me
she wants to take care of children she
wants to that's feminine me it is to me
it is that is what I want in a woman I
you can only speak from I can name you
the stats but I'm talking about me I'm
talking as a person name the stats so
what about the stats where all the
fathers who leave and don't pay child
support isn't that far more common than
these men who are
on custody which they only do 50% less
than women do when men want primary
custody they only file the appropriate
paperwork 40% of the time women do it
over 80% of the time and then they
complain that they're not get courts
don't give you something that you're not
asking for period so what are you saying
men choose not to support their families
they wave responsibility many times
that's very sexist to say that to assume
that fathers don't care about their kids
why aren't they acly fighting for their
kids they are it wouldn't be an issue if
it didn't happen it's an issue for a
reason there are lawyers that specializ
in this they wouldn't have a business if
it didn't happen uh I know at least for
you and possibly for Pearl you guys want
to reaffirm traditional masculine roles
which does not assume that men are the
nurturing ones and if that's going to be
the case then you're going to continue
to run into the problem where men aren't
going to get custody because women are
going to be seen as the nurturing um
gender selfing prophecy so if you don't
want that to be the case then it makes
sense to stand with feminists and want
to dismantle those sorts of norms and
expectations around what it means to be
a man and what it means to be a woman I
would say it should be 50/50 custody off
the bat women experience more sexism
than men if you agree please step
forward now I don't know about like more
but I'm coming at this from like the
point of view of like what's more
dangerous exactly like mandry men's
feelings get hurt but when it comes to
misogyny and like sex sexism women get
hurt killed so when I say when I think
of more I'm not thinking like oh they
have more they face more sexism like is
the sexism like hurting you no I the
same way I was looking at it when I
heard sexism I just heard safety yeah
that's that was my main that was the way
I was approaching at the topic was
basically men experien sexism I don't
think anybody would disagree with that
um I think the topic was just more
sexism like you said uh you know just
simple things just as like a man maybe
just 10 feet behind you at night you
know there are certain thoughts that
just run into your head just simple
ideas such as being treated differently
in the entertainment industry versus how
as a man um when I hear sexism again
like you said I view it more as just
danger you know what I mean like for men
me facing sexism like you said my
feelings might get hurt but I'm not
going to I'm not going to feel for my
life you know what I mean as opposed to
women I think they genuinely do fear for
their lives more and I think we should
work towards making a safe Society for
everybody right and I think that that's
ultimately you know what's important
aside from safety any other examples
yeah I mean I think when most people in
power are men and then they can abuse
That Power by like there the common joke
of oh she slept her way to the top like
that wouldn't be such a common joke if
it weren't for women being sexualized
and experiencing sexism so common that
is just a regular joke that we all just
accept and just go with AA she slept her
way to the top like it's funny like it's
clear that since men have so much power
and not only that but men are bigger
than us so if they want something from
us at any point they could just take it
they can and a lot of times they do and
you just have to sit there and take it
men are each other's worst enemy I feel
like a lot of the sexism that men face
that really impacts them is from other
men men make fun of each other for like
getting assaulted men make fun of each
other for like not getting the girl men
like these are things that if men really
wanted if these men's right activists
really wanted to change this notion they
would be treating their fellow man
better no I mean but they're ridiculing
them for not being masculine enough 100%
I sorry sorry just was going to say just
I agree with everything you're saying
like you said earlier men shoot
themselves in the foot and I believe
someone said earlier that men when they
talk about the loneliness epidemic it's
only about ever getting the girl but
it's never about friends about
camaraderie would exactly no yeah I what
is it like one of the things that I
think that you really touched on men
shoot themselves in the foot often
there's just this idea that it's the
same way you see poor people attacking
other poor people because they're not
getting paid enough men will attack
other men because it threatens their
masculinity or because they're insecure
in it when again I'm not like a broken
record player here it's not a real
concept masculinity is not a real
concept feminity is not a real concept
these are just things that just hold us
back and like you said it halts us from
really truly like feeling heard getting
our feelings out there and like
experiencing more empathy we need to
again destroy the system destroy the
patriarchy and come up with a system
that has empathy for everybody because
it just doesn't I think what's important
to recognize is that missandry is not a
systemic issue it's not ingrained in us
um to the extent that there is like
rhetorical mandry of like women saying I
hate all men you know it's just like
individualized like yeah sure unhelpful
things but it's not an otherization in
the same way that misogyny is um yeah I
think that the world has been largely
constructed through the male and man
lens and in a way that has otherized
women and so yeah misogyny is is is more
endemic to uh gender relations rather
than mandry being sort of like
individual outbursts of reacting to that
no exactly 100% agree okay and we're
going to bring in our disagrees but I do
want to say some of the things that you
were saying you hear from Men's rights
activists I agree I've heard that online
I haven't heard that from these people
in this discussion yet I think it's just
worth clarifying let's bring in our
disagre you start yeah go for it okay so
I would disagree that you say mandry is
not systemic cultural mandry is evident
in a lot of the laws that neglect men uh
mandry is why home less men don't have
as many shelters it's why we don't take
uh male victims of domestic violence as
seriously it's why Men's Health Care is
underfunded and there is a psychological
uh phenomenon called the women are
wonderful effect where society and
people have less empathy for men in a
general sense now there may be some
Nuance there is there could be some
negative consequences for women but
overall we see social welfare programs
and laws mostly disfavor men and even if
it's a male politician who supports that
law he's still catering to his voters
and the fact that a male politician
makes a decision doesn't Resurrect The
19-year-old drafty who was killed in
battle So when you say that mandry isn't
a thing I completely disagree it's
almost become fashionable mandry is
almost a fashionable trait among the
left and I'm not a right- Winger but I
almost feel pushed this way because when
I try and talk about men's issues I get
some very sharp reactions from the left
so I just want to respond to that just
cuz it was uh specifically directed at
me um in terms of mandry not being
systemic I agree that those issues exist
but a lot of what you're referring to is
just um the relationship between men
having um disadvantages due to like
socioeconomic status and comparing that
to benevolent misogyny which does
actually otherize women and is a form of
dehumanization that they should be
specially cared for and specially
undertaken I there was a there was a
study out of the University of Chicago
in 2005 that found that when you
actually diversify the amount of judges
in a court sex-based um discrimination
uh lessons so the reason why mandry
isn't systemic is because we don't live
in whatever the opposite of we don't
live in a matriarchy right so it's we
men do things that of course
disadvantage other men but it's not uh
because they're men they're not being
discriminated because they're it's it's
due to them being like poor or whatever
uh other sort of specific situation that
they're in and I just want to add that
uh like the reason there are women only
spaces or women only shelters is because
men are the perpetrators of most of the
crime now they are also the victims of a
lot of the crime which is why that's why
I didn't agree with the prompt because I
think it is that sexism like they did
touch on it and he to touch on it that
like oh men are supposed to Never back
down from a fight I even hear things
like oh if men men should have to know
how to fight men should have to be
aggressive and you know so these women
only spaces is because women most of the
crime that's done on women is men is
from men so it's a safer place for women
when there are no men around especially
when women that are homeless or at the
bottom ranks of society well I don't
disagree that we need a women's only
space I'm just saying there is a lack of
men's space available so there are
homeless men and abused men who don't
have spaces available we are not against
women's spaces we're just saying there
is a greater need for men spaces than
currently exist you guys are referring
to violence like it belongs to men most
of especially serious violence most of
the women that are killed domestic
violence yes they are women as one out
of three wom in the US are were victim
of domestic violence do you have an
experience to pull from that you want to
share I've been hit by women before I've
been stabbed like I've been hit multiple
times by women yet I'm a 225 PB guy of
muscle and I have 20 years of experience
you know what I did nothing I just took
it but if I were to go to the police you
know who they they would remove from the
house me my ex-wife when I was going
through a divorce told me that she'd lie
to the police in order to file the
divorce faster cuz it was taking too
much time cuz where I'm from in Canada
it's one year like they will tell you
that you need to be separated for a year
so you have a chance to rekindle but all
I'm saying is violence is violence no
matter I'm not saying that men are not
violent that's not what I'm saying what
I'm saying is I've seen women as violent
is just that it is not regarded in the
same way just as you mentioned no but
men are not taken seriously either and
the point I wanted to bring is to what
you said because you mentioned that
earlier and correct me if I'm wrong you
were saying that men are not encouraged
to speak about their feelings uh I would
say largely that's true yeah yet you're
bringing them down in your conversation
you're you're saying that being sexist
towards a man is not as big of a deal as
being towards a woman so on one point
you're saying that men should be able to
show their emotions to live their
emotion however term you want to use but
in the next sentence you're saying that
the emotion of a man don't matter as
much no tions certainly matter and I
think that you can express like
disagreement or even sadness if
somebody's being quote unquote misanger
I'm just saying it's not systemic and
that's a fact that's a matter of fact
I'm saying in the descriptive reality of
what mandre is versus what misogyny is
it's not actually systemic right so I'm
having a factual disagreement with what
men quote unquote are expressing their
feelings which I don't think the
majority of men or even a plurality of
men are expressing those sorts of
feelings that Mander is like some big
burden on them bu more laws against men
though I mean there's more laws in the
US that are disfavored to men than women
why is that like which laws like the
inconsequential draft no like what laws
access to certain Healthcare programs
prostate cancer the biggest killer of
non-smoking men is not covered under the
ACA okay women women in like half the
country don't even have a right to like
bodily autonomy don't have access to
effective contraception you're you're
comparing uh amount of Rights you compar
them wait you compare those no you you
literally just said men don't have more
rights than women you said that men have
less rights and and I asked you for an
example there's no women's you said
access you said access to to to spaces
certain welfare programs yes no so men
don't have access to male only spaces
but men do have access to and I do
believe in a strong social safety net
but there's not male exclusive spaces
because there's not gendered violence of
women against men to the same degree
that there is in
their in terms of legitimate safety in
terms of like risk of injy risk three
will face domestic violence one out of
four men face the same violence the
point is that we don't report it what do
you mean by same violence why does it
matter if it's the same or not but are
you against male only spaces existing in
the first place um not necessarily but I
don't think that it's some like
widespread systemic issue or that it's
the issue that men like necessarily
needed or I think that if you had co-ed
uh spaces I don't see why a co-ed space
would be detrimental to uh men whereas I
do see co-ed spaces can being
detrimental to women and the need for uh
women only spaces but do you think that
male victims face certain stigmas and
stereotypes I do I do believe that we
need to destigmatize the way that uh men
experience victimhood a lot of men
believe that it's demasculate to ask for
help and that is something that as a
feminist I push up against I also think
it's uh it's it's wrong to uh consider a
man less of a Man based on like how much
he earns I do believe that yeah we don't
we we should encourage men to like share
their feelings what I find ironic in
your statements is that you're literally
saying that men's feelings don't matter
as much no what what you were talking
about sexism earlier this is literally
what you said I'm just giving you a
descriptive reality of why male only
spaces don't exist I don't think that it
would be like the most intrinsic evil in
the world if a male only space existed
but it's not a like necessary part of
the way that um uh sexual or
gender-based violence is experienced by
men since I have been a kid it has been
common in the media to refer to men as
trash to say that men are the problem
men are terrible etc etc to the point
that on national TV a guy got his
chopped off and they were laughing about
it and nobody said anything and nobody
cared and if the reverse happened I
don't think it would be the same outrage
does anyone on this side want to do you
see that I agree that should be an
outrage and the reason why it isn't is
because it's considered demasculate for
men to be victims and I think that in
order to dismantle that we should
dismantle unhealthy views about
masculinity which is exactly what
feminists are trying to I I think if you
guys did a good job at that it's been a
hundred years since feminism started you
maybe have some progress I don't think
feminists care about men at all they
just want to give women special
privileges and treatment you're
basically saying that men should be
taken serious and their violence should
be taken serious but you're not
understanding that when you talk about
women being violent you're talking about
it from a patriarchal standpoint who
says though it's because patriarchy
weaponizes men to be more violent women
are seen as not culpable for their
violence it strips them of their agency
and infantilizes them for when they do
commit violence and you guys are
upholding that system by not joining us
hang on feminists support gender laws on
domestic violence in the UK in 2020
feminists actually protested against the
domestic abuse bill because they didn't
like the fact it was gender neutral the
duth model in the US feminists protest
the fact that it's gender neutral so
it's feminists who want to perpetuate
these gender roles by saying laws should
be gendered and recognize gender into
the factor so it's not you perpetuated
we want gender neutral laws yes there
may be differences in gender let that be
a case-by case decision feminists are
the ones who support laws that are by
and large gendered and inherently by
default treat men and women differently
I'm just very confused how you're
calling out feminists for like having
these um crazy views when you hear what
he's saying though um that he perceives
feminists as advocating for gendered
laws some feminists um what yeah what's
your what's your reaction to that
feminist is not a monolith yeah as a
mother I I'm a mother I have three
daughters and I have a son so when I
look at the world I'm looking at the
world for how will all of my kids
farewell in this world I don't want
anything that's gendered in one way or
another but when we're talking about
like this male spaces thing whenever men
enter a space it becomes their space
they're bigger they're stronger they're
louder and a lot of times when women
feel uncomfortable we'll just excuse our
way out and it's just naturally become a
male only space that's why most shelters
mostly have men homeless shelters like
in Denver where I live all the homeless
shelters are mostly men that's why there
are specific women shelters because if a
woman goes into that shelter when the
lights go out who knows what's going to
happen to that one little woman in this
shelter with all these men and speaking
of this all the domestic violence
shelter for men the one guy that did try
to start a domestic violence um shelter
for men and he was like a big men's
rights activist but in in the true sense
wanting men to have what you want like
domestic violence resources resources
for just for them he got so laughed out
of the world the dude ended up unal
living himself Earl Silverman yeah he
was laughed up by feminists he was laugh
by feminist too and men not m not by m
so you basically want to excuse all like
just shed yourself of all the misdeeds
of your movement is the men's movement
did not demonize Earl Silverman it was
not men's it was not Mr who demonized
Earl Silverman ITX that's what you're
saying it was feminist and the same
thing with Aaron pizy who I've
interviewed by the way feminist
demonized Aaron pizzy and erl Silverman
not M we did not demonize either of
those people we're not trying to say
that we feminist we're trying to say
that the patriarchal Viewpoint that men
like laughing at me oh look at him
trying to get resources it's a joke I
don't not subscribe to that but that's a
patriarchy talking not show me those men
because I'm around men all the time and
I'm from veterans that suffer from PTSD
to just regular dudes I'll tell you
sources you keep talking I have never
seen personally cuz you're you're asking
for personal experience I've I've spoken
to hundreds if not thousands of those
men I've never seen a guy tell another
guy you shouldn't do this or you
shouldn't behave that way because you
know what when we're with with each
other guys can just be guys but still
okay okay let me tell you my experience
then I have seen that many times I've
seen men laugh at each other for like oh
my girlfriend hit me you should have
been a man you should have like thug it
out here that happens all the time but
do you understand that maybe the guys
you hang out with are the guys you
they're so-called toxic because the
masculine men that I'm talking about
would never do that okay that's you and
there's me personal experiences right
but we agree that that men should not
treat each other that way oh yeah hey
there I know trying to find a middle
ground during a passionate debate can be
a bit frustrating and honestly it seems
like we're just circling the same points
right but when it comes to the
unexpected like you've been in a serious
accident there's no debating that you
need help and that's where Morgan and
Morgan comes in no matter who you are
and what you believe in America's
largest injury Law Firm is always on
their client side Morgan and Morgan
specializes in a wide range of personal
injury cases and have won thousands of
big cases just recently Morgan and
Morgan has secured verdicts of $12
million in Florida and $26 million in
Philly that's up to 40 times the highest
insurance offer I'm telling you your
case can be worth millions the best part
it's all free unless you win your case
and working with them is all done from
your phone without the need to visit any
offices if you've also been a victim of
a person injury or any other serious
accidents you can visit ww.
forthepeople.com juilee found in the
description below to start your free
claim today thanks to Morgan and Morgan
for sponsoring this portion of the
episode now let's get back to
it women's sexual Capital gives them an
advantage over men if you agree please
step forward
so I would say that women's sexual
Capital allows them more
opportunities some could say maybe
they're bad like in terms of sex work
right but women make much more in sex
work also um I've managed both male and
female on social media it's a lot easier
to blow up as a chick so it gives you
more
opportunity and why why do you think uh
it's easier for women to blow up on
social media um because it's looks based
so
any men love pretty women it's really
that simple and as you said likees too
sorry only fan would be the perfect
example that really does not normally
work for men but it works for women
extremely well and medical sales you
know it's another one I worked in sales
as a sales engineer I worked in sales
for more than a decade and women tend to
do better I don't necessarily see that
as a bad thing either because why not
take advantage of
the the traits the qualities that you
were born with everybody likes to look
at and I don't think it matters that
it's a guy looking at a woman or a woman
looking at a guy they like to look at
somebody that looks good but it does
tend to influence men's decision a lot
more than it does
women do you want to add anything yeah I
mean I think it's true but it's kind of
like so what I look at it's one of those
facts of life kind of things it's like
whatever you know is what it is and it's
not necessarily A Bad Thing that's the
thing it's it is it is true you'll see
it wherever you go women will get more
attention because they look better but
is that that bad of a thing I don't
think so it it it is the way it is just
is just the way it is all right let's
bring in our
disagrees yeah okay so I actually I feel
like this is perfect for me so I am a
top top top only fans Creator and I'm
also a lawyer which is is a very weird
you know you're perfect person perfect
person to talk about this and um yeah I
I have made I had a I have a lot of you
know lot of money from doing only fans
but I was always also Vil I've never
been more vilified either for using my
sexual capital in order to make a living
whereas when I was a lawyer and all
throughout school I was always hated I
was always just looked at cuz I had like
a more curvy body and everything so I do
think women can capitalize off of their
sexual power but I also think they are
also demonized and B ified and even when
they aren't trying to capitalize off of
it people still see them as just
that we also see cases of like porn
started dying um there's a lot of I feel
like a lot of men like to oole out women
like to see them um objectify them but
they don't see them as human so I don't
know uh so women might capitalize off of
that but I don't necessarily see that as
like net positive for them if they're
being vilified for doing something that
obviously has a market for it um I just
think it's very hypocritical why do you
find it hypocritical because there are
men that literally watched this content
that subscribe to these people and then
they demonize the same people they're
giving money 247 this is a man's problem
not a woman's problem men need to
control themselves and I think if women
have a t of sexual Capital who gave it
to us it's not us we're not the ones
that are just deciding I'm going to be
powerful because I have a body that's
not what's happening it's men that never
learned how to deal with their emotions
and their feelings and their urges that
wasn't taught to them so they don't know
how to do that so now they give women
all this sexual capital and then also
want to vilify us for it and make us the
bad guy for it but you're the one that's
noticing the pretty girls you're the one
that's giving us this I didn't ask it's
funny because when I'll go with my
boyfriend sometimes I'll go places and I
get five chicken tenders instead of four
or you know we go buy a drink or yeah I
get two drinks and I come home and I'm
like look what I got and he's like that
never happens to me and I'm like oh
silly I'm not asking for I guess a
followup though that what they might ask
or that I would I'm curious about is do
you think there's like a natural that's
just a sort of natural pattern or order
to how men and women operate or do you
or do you feel like that's conditioned I
think it's conditioned because it is so
refreshing and welcome and amazing when
I meet a man who does not treat me that
way they do not treat me like a sexual
object they treat me like a person they
talk to me like a person they give me
what I paid for I get my item and I
leave and there's no weird like did did
I owe him anything did he can I respond
to that in my personal experience men
only talk to women they want to sleep
with yeah in my personal experience
women have to be attractive on top of
their job you can't just be a lawyer you
have to be an attractive lawyer can't
just be a dentist you have to be an
attractive dentist I think when men talk
about sexual capital and women it's
because they literally ignore Every
Other Woman in that area there's like
this concept of like men get put into
friend zone women get put in the zone so
do you think that you know some of what
I heard is it is what it is men are
attracted to beautiful women so there's
kind of a natural order argument this is
just the way we behave whether it's
biologically or do you feel that it's
conditioned I do think it's conditioned
can I respond to that I think it's a
little both I do think that that is a
little bit of the natural order of
things but like for instance I think a
big like my only really interaction with
these man spaces or the Manis feere
spaces are these like red pill podcasts
that I've gone on a million times like
fresh and fit whatever where they bring
on women like me that are making all
this oh you're on only fans they bring
in all these sex workers and then they
tell us we're low value nobody will ever
love us we're for the streets and they
do all of that and then my comments get
flooded with that that's conditioned
can I just say say MRA fresh and fit
really
sucks you do not like them they are
trash they're garbage they're from South
Florida unfortunately I does but why do
only fans problem with them women go on
the W podcast yeah that's a good
question it's because the same men Their
audience that hates us they're also
making me a ton of money exactly
like you're pretty much a prop for them
to make more money cuz they'll they'll
have you on the podcast and you'll be
like the eye candy but they don't
actually care about your opinions
they're just using you as a prop to put
down and so that could feed into their
audience people people don't respect sex
workers because it's easy to take your
clothes off that's why they don't
respect them it's also easy to open your
mouth people people respect things that
are hard and sex work only fans that's
not hard and why is it that people still
respect like Leonardo DiCaprio sleeping
with small it's really easy for him to
do that nobody bats an eye for him
sleeping with who with when extremely
rich and wealthy successful men wait
when exem Rich successful healthy and
goodlooking Men sleep with a lot of
women even though it's easy for them to
do so they're not looked down on the
same way that like for example a sex
worker maybe using her body it's also
important to note that like this whole
idea of like um sex workers and um only
fans girls like making a ton of money is
extremely new who owns like 99% of the
actual porn industry in the the
Production Studios it's men men
historically and even today still are
the ultimate benefactors of women's
sexuality and men only started getting
upset about porn and all this stuff when
women started making their own money on
only fans men did not complain about
porn before the proliferation of only
fans these podcasts did not exist back
thenl what do you
think
um was it difficult for Leonardo
DiCaprio to become rich and successful
is that a difficult thing to do um it in
his case maybe but for a lot of men not
necessarily to be a world renown do you
think it do you think it you just answer
yes or no is that hard to do
question what do you what do you think I
think it's hard to do and that's why
people respect it do you think being a
sex worker is easy to do so people don't
respect it lots of people do easy things
they start YouTube channels spewing
nonsense fans also don't make a lot of
money the record most only fans girls do
not make money they don't and they're
not respected either are are are men who
were born into wealth and naturally
good-looking when they sleep with a lot
of women are they demonized for that and
called
no no so it doesn't matter whether or
not it was difficult for them to get to
a high status or if they were just born
into it I would say being a man doesn't
prude they're not demonized but it's
generally difficult for men to be
selected by a lot of women and the
dating app stats will back that up
that's again so again I know you're
asking about demonization but the
original question was why does Leonardo
DiCaprio celebrated it's because it is
hard being a sex worker is easy you just
so you just said he's celebrated because
it's hard but I you just admitted
earlier wait you just also admitted
earlier that that a guy who is
successful and and born into wealth and
born into a naturally good-look body is
also celebrated for sleeping a lot of
that's not really B it's not so it's not
actually contingent on whether I'll make
a caveat I would say even men still need
to learn to be attractive to women even
if they're born into wealth and
naturally goodlooking women also need to
learn how to bect
that's are you calling us just dumb dogs
or something but I some of the top only
fans creators aren't attractive at all
can I ask that's subjective that's
subjective clearly not I think I have a
question you say being a sex worker is
easy but look at the I know you love
statistics how come most only fans women
don't earn a living off make L because
they don't care about money they like
attention and that was the that was the
big thing when I interviewed a bunch off
of interviewing a bunch of only fans
models and they'll tell you that a lot
of them do they say I just enjoy taking
off my clothes on camera well let's hear
from somebody who has experienced do you
want to respond to that uh that's
absolutely not true I mean just to use
my anecdotal experience I didn't even
have social media before I started I
have an Instagram I do not care about
attention I just wanted to make a lot of
money which is why people do only fans
why would they want to get attention
it's a lot of it's negative too A lot of
people hate you a lot of people think
you're no one's going to marry you blah
blah blah I don't believe those things
but I'm also able to advocate for I'm a
lawyer so I'm more gifted in being able
to combat that rhetoric these girls are
not and a lot of these girls that are
going into this I'm the exception they
don't have other options they're not
super educated they don't have other
avenues to try to make a living and then
a lot of them when they do go in this
when you say it's easy it's not easy to
make a ton of money on o fans I had to
do a ton of marketing I had no social
media following ahead of it you could
say okay well you look a certain way or
whatever but a lot of the women that
enter this if it was so easy they
wouldn't be not making money well I
would disagree that there's no other
option you guys can get jobs just like
the men to I look at what people say
versus what they do you might say that
you didn't care about attention but I
look at the way you behave and dress and
it would indicate other way to the real
job to you and you're more scantily clad
okay so why what are you looking for
attention o
okay let's not do personal attacks it's
not really going to work out for us
let's move on there is a new episode of
radical empathy out now I had an
interview with a only fan star who is
also a virgin go listen to it after you
watch this episode Middle Ground
feminism is trying to remove masculinity
from
society if you agree please step
forward all right ni start us
off you know I think the best thing to
say is probably that they're trying to
be masculine so they're trying to remove
what masculinity is today and replace it
by
a version of femininity that is
masculine who's they feminists oh god I
thought that's who we were talking about
got it got
it
yeah I think that feminists are against
anything that's actually
masculine so they're trying to get rid
of it is what you say but I think it's
more than that they're kind of replacing
it they're kind of trying to redefine
what masculinity is so you know what
probably the better answer is
traditional mascul
is being replaced by something that is
not masculine at all well and the
question is how do you raise masculine
men you need fathers in the home to
teach them it and feminism have given
incentives to take the father out of the
home and do you want to give us a few
examples before we pull these guys in
well what percent of men actually get
custody of their children it's 50% of
their DNA why don't they get 50%
custody mhm
all right let's bring in our
disagrees men typically get custody of
their children way more often than not
when a woman rightfully and honestly
gives her experience of domestic
violence in the marriage she's more
likely to lose custody of her children
there is no issue with men getting
custody that's absolutely true you're
just making numb what percent of what
percent of the time do men get custody
of their at least 50% of the time what
you're thinking about that is not
true 77% of the time 90% of the cases do
not even go to Family Court no but but
the question is why and that's I had the
same no I had the same I had the same
thought when I first heard it I would
ask like why aren't men fighting for
custody but the problem you get is the
lawyers will tell them not to even fight
because it's so expensive and you have a
you have a 10% don't even file the
appropriate paper are you blaming
feminism for that wait I think the
statistics and the numbers that you're
thinking of and that you're talking
about are from the 70s it was from a
psychologist Dr Gardner he was the one
who invented the term parent alienation
and he was very biased in gearing it
towards women he was later discovered to
also be defending pedophilia the parent
alienation has never been in any DSM
never recognized by anyone even the
World Health Organization so more often
than not now that women are working and
men are working custody is very much
spit down the middle who gets the major
custody the majority of the time men or
women so men who fight for custody
actually are far more likely get to get
back to the question I found the
question somewhat too vague I mean do
feminists want to erase masculinity it's
kind of too abstract and vague to answer
so my problem is when feminists try and
redefine masculinity or they try and say
this is our interpretation of toxic
masculinity as we see it that's kind of
the problem that I have um I don't like
it when feminists tell men how they
should feel how they're supposed to feel
this is how your experience as a man is
supposed to go and that is where I would
have the issue with that I would say
that yeah so people say oh masculine
like men are all supposed to be
masculine and women are always supposed
to be feminine as if there's no overlap
while there may be differences between
men and women are average a lot of times
those effect sizes are pretty small and
to have a society where we have this
rigid like you're a woman therefore this
is the best job for you you're a man so
this is the best job for you that's not
how you have a flourishing Society
actually based on meritocracy where the
people best suited for a particular role
or a particular job or more passionate
about it can go do that so if women want
to stay at home they can if they don't
they don't have to same for men many
people also have a mix of femininity and
masculinity can I expand on that
actually go ahead in my experience I
feel like uh what is when it comes to
redefining masculin that's not even a
real concept we need to abolish gender
as a whole because the ideas um that's
pretty much raising the whole masculine
that's not even a real concept feminine
is not a real concept these are just
things that were designed long Long Ago
by people who abolish gender yeah it's
not real it's not real it's a human
constuct if the if the complaint is that
feminists which aren't synonymous with
women obviously we have two male
feminists right here if the complaint is
that feminists want to reconstruct a new
idea of masculinity that is actually
healthy that allows men to realize when
they are victims when they are going
through things like depression or or uh
suicidal um or
alienation any or any matter for that
fact we have to recognize that that is
going to be to the benefit of men right
so which but I don't know anybody
especially me I'm as masculine as they
come I would never say that that's wrong
what you just said is absolutely right
but the point in the matter is there are
things that women do better than men
they're better caretaker they care more
they love more this is why if you look
at the University of Ottawa studies they
show that within the next 10 20 years 75
to 90% of caretakers will be women as in
medicine not just nurses we're talking
all across the board but does it have to
be that way does it always have to be
that way that but hold on that
completely sidestep the point I was
making do you deny that when a man cries
it's considered Dem mascula no not at
all they whoever day is is saying that
this is what a man should be the thing
men don't deal with their emotions the
same way women do because they're not
taught to from childhood because you're
a boy you get a truck you're a girl you
get a doll you're going to be good at
cooking go play in the toy kitchen
you're a big tough man go get the army
soldiers that's why basically do you
think you have the special answer of the
right way to tell the kid of course she
does I think when you when you let a
child when you look at having children
as I'm bringing independent thinking
little humans into this world and I want
them to grow into whoever they are meant
to be whatever that is whether it's a
male ballerina or a female NFL coach I
want this little person that I love so
much to be whatever they want to be no
one's arguing with that okay so here's
what I think um I agree that people
should not be locked into a role either
way I think that if you took 10 million
men and 10 million women and you track
them over 10 years you might see certain
Trends emerge now it doesn't mean you
have to be this or you have to be that
people should be free to be whatever
they want but I do think that you would
see certain Trends emerge now is what
might some of those be well you might
see on average boys are more likely to
play with GI Jo's and girls are more
likely with Barbie are straight
statistics coming straight out of his
like whatever we cannot go off of like
statistics in the numbers that you're
coming up with on the fight you make
good point but I feel like you're
talking about social conditioning you're
saying you assume there would be some
there would be Trends if you ran that
study yes but that's that's his
assumption not an actual stat but do you
does anybody on the feminist side have
do you believe that masculinity is a
thing well I mean it's it's it's a thing
in the way that every like race is also
a thing it's not it's not biological
it's not fixed but it's a real social
construct that does have real impacts on
people's everyday lives and I understand
what you're saying that there are going
to be uh deviations and differences and
the test is whether or not those
deviations are socially constructed
environmental or biologically based but
I think that we have no clue to the
extent the way that things are truly
socially constructed for Millennia women
have been barred out of like educational
purpose but now women are actually out
out graduating men they're actually
earning earning better grades than men
in many instances you have nothing of a
to I would agree I think it's a mixture
of uh biology and conditioning so it's
interesting to um imagine a 100 years
from now how will it play out but I do
think it's a mixture of both so I do
agree with that that's nature versus
nurture we've known that we've
understood that it's that's nothing like
mind-blowing and new you said you were
the most masculine person here can you
define what masculinity is exactly I
would like to hear that five things a
man's a provider he needs to be a
protector he needs to have faith he
needs to have courage you got it so if
they don't do that they're not masculine
by your definition why is Faith
masculine you have to believe okay to
answer your question I'll ask you a
question how do you build
self-confidence you don't need Faith to
do that you don't need Faith to do that
no you don't hold on you're assuming
that faith I'm talking about God don't
assume what I'm assuming no but faith in
yourself your self self self-belief
starts with believing in yourself that's
faith cuz at the beginning you won't
believe why is that masculine though
anybody could have that do you think
that there's masculinity no it's not a
real concept femininity is not a real
concept aren't you a men's rights
activist I'm a men's rights activist but
that's just the other same side of uh
that's the same side what's it called
same side of feminism I believe in
destroying the patriarchy I believe in
destroying the ideas of gender I agree
with everything you're saying because
the ideas that you guys are talking
about with how men are emasculated not
allowed to cry or people think their
emotions AR AR valid I agree with all
that that's not women's fault and those
aren't even like masculine traits these
are all just ideas that were just fed To
Us by the patriarchy and we need to
destroy it why are you a men's rights
activist um only because I feel like
this side understandably has a lot of
Bad actors and grifters and there aren't
a lot of people on this side who
thoroughly align themselves with
feminists I have a lot of friends who
are feminists I align myself with most
uh trans feminist and feminist of color
the reason why I'm mostly on this side
is honestly just because I can
sympathize with the plight of most men
not feeling valid and not feeling heard
and I think that should be talked about
the problem is is the people who are
leading that conversation tend to be
folks who are still rooted in the
concept of gender and I think that's
detrimental to the movement and when you
think about it feminists and men's right
activists could work together I agree
100% yeah we want a society where the
like for instance like she said earlier
oh it's cuz women are going into these
useless Majors like I'm a lawyer half of
our profession is women half of the
medical profession doctors are women
right this idea that men have to be the
providers when half of us households
have women earning almost as much as
much or more than men it's because women
are good at these jobs women are like I
do ve I did very well on the outside I
did very well in law school so for you
to say oh women are feminine and they're
not they're supposed to just sit at home
and be nurturers then in a meritocracy
well in a meritocracy a lot of women
that kids I you if men are supposed to
be providers if that's masculinity then
what's femininity I never said that a
woman needs to stay home name the five
name the five thingsin women and men
compliment each other well that how
would a woman compliment masculinity
Mass it's a good question how would a
woman compliment you know what take if I
take my example because that's all I can
talk about my girlfriend will stay at
home with the kids so that's
complimenting no no but that is her
choice I understand I choose to provide
and I do not want you think it's
feminine for her to stay at home this is
a choice that her and I made I found a
partner that is more traditional in her
values she wants to raise children
that's what she wants I come from a
broken down family where my dad left
when I was 14 and he never came back I
needed a father figure to teach me what
it is to be a man because a woman cannot
teach a boy how to become a man neither
can I teach a girl how to become a woman
so in my choice when I want children I
want a woman that will stay with them
that will teach them love that will
teach them to be compassionate and I
think their followup would be do you see
your partner taking that role as as
inherently feminine more so than if she
went to be a neuros of course CU I I
believe in a more traditional role but
that doesn't mean that you're wrong if
your husband wants to stay home I don't
have a problem with that I believe that
men and women complement each other men
should go to therapy agree or step
forward
sorry so I I would be very cautious when
it comes to um I'm not against it per se
but it's just I think there's a lot of
things that are not completely uh sound
but I'm not against the idea of men
going to therapy if you find a good
therapist and it helps you sure yeah
good therapy um not weap like I think
what you're talking there is a some
people that weaponize therapy talk that
basically try to psychoanalyze people
and use false like stereotypes about
them but good honest therapy I feel like
men women everybody could benefit from
that and I feel like as men's right
Advocates you guys should be striving
for men you know taking their mental
health more serious has it benefited you
if you I used to take therapy back in um
High School um due to like you know
uncertainty about the future and my
academics and stuff like that and it it
did me good and I feel like a lot of
people just need someone to talk to and
therapist is you know that's what
they're made for you know well I will
say personally um I do think therapy is
important but I do have a problem with
how it seen as like the end all be all
solution to men like true to me America
is such an isolationist country that
even our forms of healing are
isolationist like go out somewhere come
back healed yeah the solution is always
therapy and pills it's never Community
or compassion right and I think that
should be like to me everybody I know uh
I've done therapy personally I've been
in it for a couple of years yeah it's
fine but what really has helped me is
just finding Community finding other
friends talking to people um not that
could be therapy in itself no it is it's
just but there's a definition of therapy
that I think is wrong and that's why I
was hesitating because Community explain
what you mean for men especially and
again I can't talk for women I'm not a
woman but for men especially we lack the
interaction with other men without
having women involved yes that's true
and this is why I love martial art this
is absolutely why it has made me the man
that I am today because I got to bleed
to literally physically hurt somebody
else but it was always in a control
matter I am a violent man by Nature I'm
but I meditate every day I have my
violence under control because I was
shown techniques to control myself that
were taught by community of men so
martial arts is your therapy but not
talk therapy the word therapy that's
misused men need therapy but do they
need to go see a psychologist or they
just need to go to Street somewhere for
a few weeks where it's just dudes cuz
unlike and I'm I'm going to assume here
but I have spent years alone in the
Woods by myself in meditation just
reading and you know what hardest thing
I've ever done in my life but I needed
to do it that's true I built a community
of men around me they might not be
physically with me but I have two guys
that I can call no matter what does not
matter what it is but they're older than
me they're the age of my parents because
they're mentor to me and this is what
men need they don't need somebody to
talk to that's going to make them feel
better they need somebody to be there
for them and this is where we lack I
cannot remember the statistics or the
numbers themselves but after 30 most men
don't have any friends anymore yep they
literally are alone and that's why men
kill themselves they have nobody to
depend on they have nobody to call you
know there's the expression to say do
you have a guy that you can call 3:00 in
the morning to say bring a shovel don't
ask why but I need you to bring a shovel
and if you have a truck I'd like that
too is that a good thing but the point
is that it's a Do or Die friend and most
men do not have that cuz women do tend
to bond it's easier for women to bond it
is just think that like many men can
bond with other men but I feel like
instead of doing that they look at women
to solve their no I I agree with that
actually I think a lot of I think I see
this a lot in the men's rights activist
movement where basically again we turn
to women to use our use their emotional
labor to sort of like you know kind of
just oh women are natural caretakers and
they're not nobody's a natural anything
and it's a thing where we need to start
doing that for each other like again
I've been in three men's mental health
spaces and it's all usually just
predominantly just me and a bunch of
other Progressive men just talking about
pretty much just how we feel about the
world and that's really that has done
more for me personally than therapy has
right um and I think that's sort of like
I'm glad that you have that Community
with those two men I think that's
important to have I wish more men had
that because that's what's needed yeah I
agree and however you call it like you
can talk it it's more Progressive I did
it through martial arts it's some do it
through business one of my mentors a
business Mentor but he's like my father
but I do think we also need to emphasize
that men need to also hold each other
accountable just be like you know um
enforcing each other's bad habits and
qualities they should be a healthy
community community of everybody needs
an in their life and that's
normally me but you need somebody that
will call out your faults you need
somebody that's going to be we so that
is all part of the men Community you
will find a guy like that if you don't
you should definitely don't expect women
I think that women are really good at
finding a lot of fulfillment in their
platonic friendships um uh there's often
the case where we talk a lot about uh
lonely men there uh you know women are
like Maring marrying less to but they're
a lot less depressed over it because
they find so much fulfillment and
connection
uh with their uh interpersonal friends
and then in terms of uh therapy um you
know I I I I work with therapists for
like my day-to-day job and there's
definitely like bad therapists out there
but um as an aggregate you know uh
therapy is clinically proven to be you
know generally more beneficial than not
and it is also proven that men
statistically are less likely to seek
out therapy and so yeah I think I think
that whole the definition of therapy
that matters too there a lot a lot of
the men that I know and again I've dealt
with thousands of them it is not done
through a psychologist it is done
through physical activity there actually
is evence and I think that both are are
necessary I think that seeking out a
professional dep on the person might
work for you might not work for Meir and
you need to actually open up when you
talk that was actually that actually the
thing I was going to say you always do
you know the best conversation I've ever
had is when somebody just punched me in
the face we're both exhausted and we sit
there but no but I'm different from you
obviously we're not the same so to laugh
at what I'm saying vent by Nature not at
all everybody's violent I disagree no no
IE I want her to fly but just the way
you've rolled your eyes at some of my
comments shows violence you might not be
physically violent but the way you're
responding is in a violent way you just
put a different definition on it the way
you deal with your problems and I'm not
saying you're right or wrong you know
better than I do on how to deal with
your problems what I'm saying is the
best conversations I've ever had is
after physical exertion
with another men let's bring in our
disagreer I forgot you
there so the only reason I disagree um
is because I think most therapists are
crazy in college you know I would see
all the girls that would be psych majors
and they're always insane so I think if
you have a 100 therapists more will do
more harm than good I can understand if
you don't agree with that but that was
the only reason I stayed I think if you
find a good therapist man or woman it's
fine very convenient you the field that
most women are into shame and disregard
it's like why you seem to always attack
women's fields and like degrade them and
say they're not like I I have that's my
experience that's my experience good for
you well she was asked about uh therapy
so that's the feeli that came up yeah
but take itly no but I think but it's
it's noticing a pattern of put a man
dominated field you think she would be
saying the same thing I don't I don't
think so well men dominated Fields
usually do better so can I piggy back on
something Ariel said um he was talking
about how you know men should go to
therapy because it helps reduce the
emotional labor that their Partners have
to do and I totally agree with that that
is exactly a reason why because I can't
tell you the pretty much every romantic
relationship I've been in there's some
element of me like teaching them how
what their feelings are and especially
now that I have children that's even a
reason why relationships break down
because when I can see a man and his
behaviors are exactly parallel to my
8-year-old I'm like okay so we don't
know how to deal with our feelings we
don't know how to talk what's that
behavior having a complete tantrum a
complete meltdown because something
didn't go their way I expressed you know
hey something you did really hurt me and
I you know I don't like that and can we
talk about that because I love you and I
want to save this relationship and that
turns into it hurts me that I hurt you
and now I'm really sad and so they can't
even be man enough to sit there and have
a conversation about their feelings
knowing that the reason I brought this
up is because I love you so much the way
you're talking right now I I it would be
very difficult for me to have a ation
this to me is extremely abrasive and I
would probably just walk away I love
what you were saying cuz I honestly do
agree with that I think a lot of men
weren't taught emotional vulnerability
and emotional availability and it's
honestly disheartening because you see
how that stunts them later on kind of
like you said like they can't even
maintain relationships like you again
like that's just a good example right
there like you are doing the emotional
labor for the relationship men are not I
do think that bringing it back to
therapy I read somewhere that talk
therapy isn't that good for men and I I
read somewhere one of the reasons for
that is because men we're not taught to
handle emotions seriously our emotions
are discarded so we tend to discard
other people's emotions and it's again
very sad to see so I don't think therapy
traditional talk therapy that may not
work for everybody i' like what you said
about martial arts I think that's you
know if that works for people it works
for people I think that stuff like that
is important um I think men that's why
we got to hold other men accountable
that's why you have to have guys who be
like hey man I think the way you're
treating your girl is wrong I think
you're using her to too much for
emotional labor I think it's important
to realize that when you are asking
someone to be your wife you're not
looking for someone to serve you which I
think some men honestly do go into
marriage with that intention you're
looking for a partner and I think a lot
of men sort of forget that it's
important for women to become mothers
will the agre please step
forward odd one out Nico what's that
you're the odd one out it's just
statistic base they say that women are
twice as prone as men to be depressed
and women in their 30s without children
are twice as much likely to be depressed
than mothers in their 30s do you think
it's in their best interest to become
mothers well I guess that depends on the
person but without mothers we're not
going to continue the human race right
so maybe that that ties up to your your
last question men are attracted to women
because they there's a biological need
to reproduce women tend to have more
attention from men that's how they made
it MH and that's how the race survived
for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years right but do you
would you go so far as to think we
should encourage all women to be
mothers I don't think everybody should
be parents have you looked at the kids
that're being raised or the kids that
don't have children like if I'm not not
capable of having children I'll adopt
mhm but is it for everybody I don't
think so and generally speaking it's not
everything's for everybody so but only
women can be mothers so it's very hard
for me to say that they shouldn't be
encouraged to be mothers got it all
right let's bring in all of our disagre
years motherhood is such a huge
undertaking and I feel like there's not
enough education for girls young girls
and women of all the physical side
effects that can happen to you like down
to the smallest thing like hair loss
your teeth like all the calcium
everything goes to the baby everything
goes to the baby the thing that really
upsets me about like motherhood and
putting this pressure on women to to
become mothers is like women who
struggle with infertility um when you
tell women that like your whole purpose
in life is to be a nurturer a mother to
take care of children that leaves out
such a section of women that had whether
it's they just naturally couldn't have
babies or you know they had some sort of
cancer they lost an ovary they lost
something and now these women are going
to be stuck with no identity just like
lost in the world because your whole
purpose is to be a mother and then it's
wild because when you become a mother it
is not at all what it seems like you
know it's not all Pinterest and cutesy
what it seems like it's super
overwhelming there's a ton of um
hormones that run through your body
postpartum depression all the things
that happen to you and to put that
pressure on women just because we're the
only ones that can have babies would you
consider being a mother one of your
greatest achievements like is that what
brought you the most Joy cuz as
difficult and I'm not going to argue
with you that it's difficult I'll never
know right we can agree to that but
would you say that it brought you it's
one of the experience that brought you
the most Joy the most purpose the most
fulfilling is the word I would use um I
would say that has to be balanced with
it's also the hardest scariest most
terrifying thing I've ever done so it
doesn't bring me the same amount of Joy
because for as much joy as it brings me
it brings me Terror and fear I have
three little girls one of them is
disabled the the incident of you know
offenses that happen to little girls
that are disabled like her is super high
so while yes it does bring me joy and
fulfillment the amount
of you know sleepless nights and stress
and tears that it causes me is it needs
to be right up there with in that
conversation you cannot talk about one
without the other I don't think it's
important for women to become mothers
but I do think being a mother is
important but women should have the
choice to indulge in motherhood um it
shouldn't be like this thing that you
know perpetuate this this idea that
women should always be mothers but I do
think women that choose to be mothers
should be respected and what they're
doing is important I think that most
women that don't have children will
regret it but I've met enough I said
most most but I have met enough women
that I don't see a nurturing bone in
their body and are very self-centered
that I don't think would benefit like I
don't think they could really um be
mothers and like raise the kids and put
them first so I think it depends on the
person mhm um this is very personal
would you go so would you be comfortable
sharing do you have your own Ambitions
to become a parent yeah I want to be a
mom can I can I just say um I'm actually
friends with a few women who've had
their ovaries removed just because of um
some sort of illness or just disability
and they subscribe to the notion of
simply just you know motherhood is
important but they they can never be a
mother that has been a thing that
they've accepted a long time ago and
that said they don't vehemently hate
children they don't look down on anybody
who has children it was just something
that isn't in the card for them I do
think however that if we can if we do
agree that motherhood is important I
think we shouldn't look down on Single
Moms I think single motherhood is a very
difficult thing and I think the stigma
against single moms is pretty negative
and kind like what you said earlier you
know like it's important for women to be
moms I think that also should apply to
single moms as well exactly I would I
would disagree just because there are a
lot of problems when you have kids that
are coming from single mother homes so I
think you should be sexually responsible
and only
have kids with someone that is going I
know people I know people who personally
have had children with men who they
thought were really good people and then
either it didn't work out either they
were a widow or either something just
happened to where they became a single
mom you don't know anybody's full story
a lot of times women are getting
pregnant from guys they're not even in
real relationships with um why you
blaming the mothers and not the men what
about men practicing sexual
responsibility you have anything to say
about that I'm curious Pearl what's the
point you're trying to make that most
single mothers could have prevented
being in that situation yeah okay I'm
like the fathers couldn't have you know
kept it in their pans right right I I
you know men should be sexually
responsible too but at the end of the
day when there's an accidental pregnancy
women have the choice to get an abortion
men don't have the choice to get a
financial abortion not every woman has
aice so women so women have more Choice
okay what is stopping a woman from
getting an abortion in the US laws
plenty of laws plenty of law wait wait
wait okay so you rent a car go to
another state that's that become illegal
Toole not I don't look it I don't think
it's if one out of three women have had
an abortion in the United States I don't
think by the time they're 45 I don't
think it's that difficult to get
one was just overturned in what like 20
more and there were more abortions
couple years and there were more
abortions the year after Row versus weed
them before so your own takes a few
years for a lot of theer laws like
States like Arizona and Texas to
actually kick in so a lot of those
didn't even kick in until like spring
summer of this year but what I'm
advocating for is as a woman you have a
ton of choice there's Plan B there's
like 20 forms of birth control you can
require the guys that you're sleeping
with to put on a condom you can get an
abortion like there's so many choices
that if you are in the situation where
you are a single mother you didn't make
one bad choice you made like 10 bad
choices but you're not pro-choice though
you think abortion is murder do you
think abortion should be accessible
so I am
pro-life we go pro life so and that
comes from because I have a um my
parents they got pregnant when they were
teenagers and they had the choice to
abort my brother and they ended up
giving him up for adoption and so I met
my brother when I was 22 and he's like
this awesome guy he's married now with
kids how sad would it have been if I
didn't get the opportunity to meet my
brother and my mom didn't choose life I
I don't have children and I'm still
deciding whether it's something I want
but glad that now it's Being Framed more
of a choice than as something you have
to do like I'm I've loved hearing your
experiences because before when it was
like I mean my parents are both
immigrants from Iran and over there like
it's just there's no like oh what if
it's like something's wrong with you if
you're not going to be a mom and I much
rather have the people that are parents
are people who want to be parents the
people who have all the information and
still say this is something I want to do
then something that you should do
otherwise you're not as much of a woman
right and it's when we frame things is
women are supposed to be nurturing and
then if you don't have anyone to nurture
what do you like not a woman now so
that's one of the reasons these like
gender Norms I think are not helpful I
also think we need to talk about the
absolute hatred of like women who choose
not to be mothers that I've seen online
I feel like we should all have like some
respect for people who want to choose to
do what what you know what their lives
is they they choose and I don't think
that you know I'm not going to shame
somebody for becoming a mother and I
don't think somebody should be sh shamed
for being a mother I think there needs
to be like just respect for every as an
example uh Trump's vice president IAL
pick JD Vin said like one of the biggest
problems of the country was single cat
ladies who aren't going to get married
and not have kids he said they shouldn't
be able to vote and so that's just
evidence that like one of the
potentially most powerful people in this
country is blaming single women who
aren't mothers and the kind of pressers
associated with women needing to fill
the um motherhood role I feel like women
are so conditioned to want to have
children like going back to our earlier
conversation like little girls are given
a baby doll and little girls are you
know kind of you know orted that way to
do those types of things and so a lot of
women mothers are afraid to even talk
about how much motherhood is not
fulfilling how lonely it feels how scary
it is how it's it's not everything you
thought it was going to be and there are
times where I think like life would be a
lot easier if I didn't have kids right
now if I didn't have this whole mess
everything I did everything right I
married the guy I waited a few years we
had kids we did everything correctly and
it still fell apart what happened I
wasn't being respected in my marriage
and when I decided to stand up and ask
for that that wasn't given so I hadan by
not respected I'm not I don't want to go
into the full details of my marriage
just trying to find a way to blame you
yeah you're trying to find a way because
what you're trying to do is you're using
yourself as an example so I'm asking
question what we're supposed to do and I
just don't want to get into the Nitty
Gritty details of my divorce but I
wasn't being respected as a human I
wasn't treated as a human I was treated
as a baby making machine take care of
the kids make sure they're good that's
it oh once having a heart problem who
cares another baby oh another heart
surgery who cares another baby when you
look at women as just that oh they're
here for children they're here to have
babies you dehumanize them Andrew Tate
is having a positive influence on
society if you agree please step
forward that's going to be
interesting you guys go for it
so I don't agree with every single thing
he says I don't agree with every single
thing he's ever done but I think overall
he has a positive message he tells guys
to work hard go to the gym and
he I think overall his content is
positive it's mostly the delivery that
people don't like about an inju because
what do you mean by that he can sound
condescending to people like he can
sound very abrasive
to people and as she says I don't agree
with everything that he that he's I
don't know anybody I've ever agreed with
everything that they say even me six
months ago there's probably things I
don't agree with now but at the same
time we have to remember who the message
is for too and how that message is
served it's served through social media
where the person that screams the
loudest is going to be heard you know
you say it's positive but um what is
that positive impact to say to work hard
to to young men to tell them because one
of the things he says a lot and I would
say the same thing to young men stop
worrying about women when you're young
and develop yourself as an individual
cuz if you look at history that is how
men show value men are always judged by
what they bring to the table well in my
opinion comes from during his whole
court case and when he was going super
viral I covered him a lot and I would do
Street interviews so I would I would
talk to young men that said he changed
their life so I can't how am I going to
say it's a negative if I'm I'm talking
to the actual people
yeah what would the young men say they
would say they started going to the gym
they started making more money um and
they generally improved their life
because they saw his content okay um
let's bring in all of our
disagrees let's start off with you just
uh going against the grain on your side
okay well I say screw in Tate uh he's
horrible um I'm part of several MRA
spaces and we denounce him completely uh
seen his video of his so-called boot
camp for men where he just basically
bullies men so dumb I'm not saying he
doesn't have any good points ever but
for the most part he's everything the
men's Rights Movement should not be like
and I don't think he's a good M can I uh
can I also add to that I feel like men's
rights activists we have a problem with
grifters on our side people who like you
you mentioned earlier you understand
social media they target young men yeah
they target young people in general just
Andrew Tate's not men not men for young
I get that you think Andrew Tate's an m
hold on hold on let me finish my thought
what I'm saying though is the guy's a
grifter he sells people the problem with
MRA activists in general is there's real
problems affecting men and Andrew Tate
will talk about that but then he'll try
to sell you on a course afterwards and
that's the problem is a lot of people on
this side take advantage of young men
because we're so starved to be safe seen
and heard that we'll take anybody but I
will say one thing though Andrew Tate is
a symptom you do have to you why he get
popular there has to be some reason why
these young men felt a need to turn
somewhere it's the same thing there's I
was going to say just real quick there's
an overlap between like uh like what's
it called Jordan Peterson and Andrew
Tate's audience and there's an overlap
between Hassan perer and FD signifier
audience they are positive examples of
masculinity who will tell you the same
things work hard and you know work on
yourself there's an overlap the only
problem is that men are just so starved
for just somebody recognizing their
emotions that they'll will just take
anybody and see someone like Andrew Tate
as hey at least he's fighting back at
least he's fighting back they don't
realize they're being taken advant
exactly would you consider him an M I
wouldn't have considered I don't
consider him that but he does talk about
men's issues from the same
Manos and M is often times have an he's
someone I would want to see I would have
called success I call him like success I
call him
aogist call him I call him a human
trafficker yeah you know call him a
criminal
yeah um you mentioned that it may be
more of an issue with delivery but he
said explicit things whereas like he
doesn't take the opinions of women
seriously there's no way of delivering
that kind of message like the issue
isn't with the delivery it's the content
of that and then additionally I would
just say any individual who is a human
sex trafficker which if you if you
listen to the videos in which he
explains how he runs his business model
it is exactly that stealing from um sex
workers and lying to them po lying to
them about um what he's paying them and
how much is going towards taxes and fees
Etc um any sort of model like that
regardless of what they're saying is not
a net positive impact on men and in fact
reinforces the same kind of sexist
misogynistic things that men need to get
over and he's also admitted to literally
robbing men taking their money because
he tricked them into thinking they were
talking with actual women behind cameras
he said this himself I'm not making that
up I'm not I'm not debating you guys at
all I said this I said that there's a
lot of things that he's done I don't
agree with either but to say that
everything he has done is negative I
could say that from anybody the the
question is Andrew Tate has had a
positive influence on society and so
Nico what I'm asking you is you're
saying you don't agree with everything
Andrew Tate does and we're hearing you
know there's things that he's explicitly
said he's done that it seems like
everybody here would probably agree as
wrong but do you think the positive
outweighs that negative I'd have to
split it down the middle like any
choices that I make in life and say a
win and a loose column and wait the
result I have a friend who he out here
in California and he he's got like eight
months to live from brain cancer um and
he his wife is paralyzed so he basically
got this diagnosis and he found out he
had eight months to live I was raising
money for him and the Tates donated like
$155,000 to him and his wife they don't
even know him and so it it's like even
just like personally I don't know them
well I've just met them once but you're
friends with them like but she's saying
I only met them once I've literally met
them once in John Wayne gasy was a kids
um clown at kids parties so really ugly
people can still do really generous
things in the world so that does not
make him a good person a broken clock
can be right twice a day doesn't make it
a clock that you want to follow when you
give someone like Andrew Tate that has
such a disgusting message that
disparages so many people in the world
and he treats people so horribly he
should not have any sort of platform
because not only is he not making the
world positive he is making the world a
much much uglier Place starting with Our
Youth and little boys that we're trying
to raise to have feelings and to be
decent contributing members of society
Tate is getting in their head since I do
only fans I make it a point I do not use
Chatters if someone's paying to talk to
me I will not defraud them and have some
person in Bangladesh pretend to be me as
a guy and talk to them Andrew Tate had
no problem scamming any of these men I
have more respect for men than Andrew
Tate does not even just women for a men
I would never scam a man whereas Andrew
Tate was just like oh these losers I'm
just going to make them think they're
talking to the this girl and find a way
to emotionally manipulate men
emotionally manipulate vulnerable men
into giving these women this money that
then he's just taking exactly what are
you doing he makes fun of men for being
broke he makes fun of men for not having
you know a bunch of women he hates men
he is the worst male Advocate you could
ever have he's a grifter the men's
Rights Movement is not as important as
the feminist movement agreer step
forward um
I don't think that it's to say that
men's issues are less important than uh
women's issues because I think that
feminism adequately addresses both
issues and I think that there are
feminists who um May in fact contribute
uh to some of you know pervasive
attitudes towards men like I always tell
girls when they say things like oh he's
not a real man unless he's like making
six figures or something like that I'm
like that's actually harmful and that's
something that like you should probably
it's in your best interest to also not
um perpetuate and so um the reason why I
would also say that the men's rights
activist movement is less important is
because I and I think even to some of
the you know more genuine uh men's
rights activists who do have good
intentions they'll acknowledge that it
is filled with toxicity and genuine
misogyny that it has a close overlap
with things like uh the red pill
manosphere pickup artists Etc um and
feminism has been here as a historical
movement and has achieved so much and so
it's ultimately the uh movement that we
should all align with um for you know
gender equality and the end of gender
depression yeah I completely agree I
mean like I know we a lot most of us
except maybe Pearl have denounced
podcasts like fresh and fit but they
literally say number one's men's podcast
so how much of these spaces are actually
filled with that toxicity and I mean the
the definition of feminism that's most
pervasive is the social political and
economic equality between the Sexes so
we I think real feminists are not the
ones perpetuating those negative
stereotypes of oh men need to be like
this men need to be providers you're not
a man if you can't do this you're not
man if you can do that and so I think
that real feminism kind of eliminates
the need for that for for men's rights
because we just want everybody to be
treated as individuals instead of um you
know treating them differently based on
their gender yeah yeah I feel like a lot
of people conflate feminism and mandry
and they just think oh if you're a
feminist that means you hate men and you
want them all to you know just suffer
and you know have a horrible life and I
feel like the people who think that
that's really their projection because
that's what their their position is like
when you're a men's rights activist and
you're like no and you're so against
feminism it's because you think feminism
is trying to replace the patriarchy with
a matriarchy and we're going to rule
just like they have but that's not the
goal of feminism the goal of feminism is
so that everybody can be the same it's
also worth mentioning feminism is a is a
diverse uh philosophy and lens of
analysis um you know Susan B Anthony's
feminism is very different from Judith
Butler's feminism is very different from
Angela Davis Simone like they all have a
variety of different approaches in the
way that they tackle issues related um
to gender sex and you know the meaning
of masculinity and femininity and so
instead of like out of protest or
wanting to address men's issues
attempting to create a new movement as
in opposition to an all a movement that
already exists and has existed for a
particular reason it's it just makes
more sense to um speak within the
variety of perspectives within this
movement that already exists a lot of
you making the argument that feminism
should be working for everybody so do
you think you should be inviting men's
rights activists to feminist spaces is
that something you would advocate for
when men come in and they want to listen
and they want the same things we want of
course we would want them into our
spaces but a lot I just I don't see a
lot of them coming in with that um
mindset gotcha let's bring in our
disagreer and Isaac let's start off with
you so I agree with everything my fellow
feminists are saying but when I entered
this discussion I was looking at male
like um rights activist from a more
antagon you know antagonistic point of
view but the more I thought about it the
more I realized that we could actually
work together yep I think feminism and
men's rights on paper yep are trying to
dismantle the patriarchy the system that
says that men must provide that you know
women should only get the kids or like
you know men are like more dangerous and
more culpable for their crime so they
should be sentenced twice as harshly as
women if we all work together we could
actually make a better tomorrow so I
don't I think feminism is more important
in the sense that we had the feminism to
open this discussion we needed it um but
men's activist can join the conversation
if they have well intentions to me I
feel like kind of what I alluded to
earlier women do so much emotional labor
for men men don't do anything for women
to me I'm on this side I agree with
almost everything you guys have said
this whole conversation and the reason
for that is the reason why I'm still on
this side is because there's a lot of
what you were alluding to a lot of
manosphere a lot of toxicity on this
side every man every movement that I've
seen that has mostly meant in it
honestly has been mostly red pill mostly
manosphere I want to that there are
men's rights activists who for the most
part want to work in Tangent with
feminism because ultimately you guys do
so much and you guys have so much on
your plate that obviously the men that
do feel that feminism maybe hasn't done
enough for them that's where I think
men's rights activists can come in pick
up the slack that maybe you guys are too
busy to deal with ultimately because
there are serious problems that women
are facing and I think men could pick up
the slack on our end for once and
actually help women I suspect there will
be comments that say that you are not a
men's rights activist of what would your
response be if we just anticipate that
com I mean it's the same way that I
would argue feminism is such a WID
spread uh men's rights activism is such
a widespread uh most of the people that
I follow the FD signifiers the Hassan
pikers those guys uh I again I'm on this
side because I think that there has to
be some examples of masculinity that
isn't against feminism that isn't
blaming women for everything you alluded
to that earlier most of the men's right
just blame women for everything I don't
support that but I do see the pain and
that's ultimately what the problem is on
this side it's mostly just grifters it's
mostly just loudmouth people who realize
that young men young impressionable men
are very easy targets and they snuff out
y'all's actual and they snuff out the
actual people like again like my friends
even ask me like why are you even on
this side I just told him like because I
ultimately know that there has to be
some people in the audience who don't
want be sucked into the manosphere who
don't want to be tox but they want to
feel heard they want to feel seen I'm
not I'm not trying to sell anybody a
course I'm not trying to sell anybody my
social media I don't do any of that
stuff I literally just want men to feel
heard and it just sucks that most of the
people on this side they're so close
because they can acknowledge men's pain
but the solutions they offer are just
messed up or they're paywalled just
because you don't agree with them
doesn't make them wrong in the same way
we were talking about um therapy earlier
sure you don't see therapy the same way
I see it no but I agre does that no no
but hold on does it make it
automatically wrong no and this is why I
don't think you're you're men's right
activist but that doesn't mean that
you're not sure it's not because I think
so that you're not but the point in the
matter is there's a there's a lot of
different ways to approach this to find
a solution to the same problem it's just
it sounds to me that whatever you don't
align with and I'm I'm talking about you
and a lot on your on your side as well
if you guys don't agree with it it's
wrong I never said that just having a
conversation with you guys is extremely
hard because we get cut off and I'm
talking about me I'm not talking about
anybody else on this panel but who
really can say
today that women need feminism name me
one right I have as a man that they
don't as a woman bodily
autonomy there may not necessarily be a
legal deser that doesn't mean that
feminism's obsolete
men's rights activists typically don't
acknowledge patriarchy in the ways that
it actually hurts men but we disagree
with feminist theory on patriarchy and
the thing is I don't think a woman's
movement should have the Monopoly on
defining a What men's issues are and B
how to address them because I will say
Decades of experience feminism does not
adequately address men's issues when I
ask feminists what are you going to do
about the boys education Gap half the
time they don't even know what it is
what can they but that's not fair like I
read Richard Reeves of Bo to men there's
a lot lot of feminists on this side a
lot of the issues you say like the draft
circumcision feminists aren't like I
don't want anyone to be drafted I don't
think men or women there are some
feminists I agree with yeah so my point
is a lot of feminism we're trying to
minimize those sex differences and what
I feel is the majority of men's rights
AC activists are trying to emphasize the
differences between men there's a lot of
feminists I agree with but when you look
at feminist organizations a lot of the
laws they Lobby for are not in the name
of equality and feminists have supported
gendered policies example like the duth
model which are not equal I'm part of
Ave movement called well organization
called the ncfm National Coalition for
men very very solid group very diverse
group men and women I would say when you
get past those big YouTubers and look at
like Grassroots men's organizations uh
we're very much about the issues and
we're not just about a backlash of
feminism so I feel like I acknowledged
that that you guys a lot of you guys are
in good faith I think what I was talking
about was that I feel like we live in an
echo chamber where we see the other side
as the enemy you see us is like you know
saying that men do not deserve any
rights um and we you know you look at us
as saying that women deserve all the
rights but I I don't really think that
that's productive men and women are
supposed to go together there's no rule
to that at all so when you say that you
know they go together that's just your
own subjective opinion so is everything
you've said up to now it's because at
the end of the day when you have a group
of people when the men want it to be
about them they can do that they can
just be stronger be bigger be louder
take over and make it about them so if
you don't com like purposely carve out
for women it doesn't happen because
you would think Common Sense would tell
you that when the Constitution says all
men created equal that they meant humans
the but the fact that women have had to
fight to get the right to you know the
gendered laws there are gendered laws so
that women could vote I think that's a
fair one because we had to gain that
right same thing with discrimination
against credit and getting bank accounts
and all that stuff like the some of the
gendered laws are there because the men
have been standing in our way damn right
so my final thought is as a woman we
have the right to do whatever we want
and I don't know what really feminists
are crying about we can go get an
abortion if we want one we can go get
birth control we can go work I don't I
can't think of anything we can't do so
to me feminism is just a lot of crying
and whining over nothing it's funny cuz
I actually like most of my life well I
someone said are you a feminist I would
be like yeah but I didn't really have to
get like adamant about it until I
switched my career into doing only fans
and was constantly attacked by again I'm
not used to and I I love like the two of
you and what you do because I do think
that there needs to be a space for
actual men like Hassan like you like you
who are giving a positive example of
masculinity okay well whatever I don't I
don't watch a moment a narrow distorted
view of masculinity and I feel like I
almost had to become a feminist in
opposition to so much toxicity and it is
unfortunately the case that the big
names are the on that are having the
most impact I would love for you guys to
be able to get more of these young men
away from sneo away from fresh and fit
away from Andrew tap but the unfortunate
truth is whatever they're spewing out to
these kids is more popular and because
of that than people like me I was like
okay all these girls are going on these
podcast and they're just being like
on because they don't have the
verbal ability or maybe like the ability
I have to combat the rhetoric so I had
to almost now everyone's like oh my God
you're such a big feminist but it's
because I had to do it in opposition to
a men's rights movement that came about
to BAS basally on us a man's right
activist movement that doesn't care
about men mind you you guys care about
men I could tell yall care about men all
right thank you all for participating in
this discussion I know it was hard it
got heated I would I think it'd be good
shake hands acknowledge each other leave
comments in good faith please thank you
for watching Middle Ground suggest more
topics in the comments for future
episodes and thank you all all right
that's wrap awesome thank
you that was cool thanks hey it was good
uh good being with you
guys definitely definitely good be with
you guys your you well Shake real fast
meting you as
well you ever seen The Walking Dead nice
meeting you dud you look like just like
one of the main